welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host Paul in this video we're
breaking down secret Invasion Episode 6.
the ending of the series is now upon us
and throughout this video we're going to
be pointing out the Easter eggs comic
book callbacks and also giving our
thoughts on the series as a whole
there's some good and bad things that
The Season's done and I want to give our
thoughts on the entire thing and where
it sits in the Marvel shows for us now
last week was a pretty slow burn with us
getting a couple of different plot
threads setting things up for this entry
Gaia and Vara threw a funeral for Talos
and unfortunately in the end he didn't
get his wish even though he sacrificed
himself to save the president we see how
come the end the guy just hates Scrolls
anyway guy and where is part of the
entry closed out with them having a
shootout with Graphics forces as for
gravic he killed Pagan for being a pagan
and we learn what his true plan was
alongside wanting to start World War III
he was also trying to get something
known as the Harvest turned out Nick had
collected The Avengers DNA and if I ever
get superpowers I'm completely [__] I
wouldn't wish anyone having to come in
my room and collect my DNA but to be
fair it is completely full of it now
going back to Avengers end game it kind
of recontextualizes Nick's appearance
and while he was at the funeral he
probably had his agents out in the field
picking up the samples now elsewhere
Sonia had been investigating around
people too and after asking her bosses
to scroll she also discovered the
Daltons reuniting with Nick they drove
out to get the Harvest and that should
be a fully up to speed as we go into
episode 6. looking back at this it makes
sense why they'd go to this specific
location to get this specific eye patch
as it's just about completing the look
and and we'll talk about this more as we
get further another breakdown
thank you
now this episode is called home which is
a central theme of the series The
Scrolls have been promised one by Fury
and in the absence of him securing one
they've decided to make earth theirs it
also kind of asks what home actually
means and whether it's a building a
place you can feel safe all the people
that make it bouncing off the back of
last week we then watch Vara at her home
and she's decided to move out from it
purple Bloodlines the walls and this is
of course what indicates if someone is a
scroll or not in the comics during the
final battle of secret Invasion there
was no way to actually test whether
someone was a Skrill or not so Black
Widow said she was just gonna start
shooting people and if they bled purple
then she'd know they were a scroll she's
basically like whoever I come across
you're getting popped in the leg and
yeah we'll decide from there exactly
whose team you're on also I think it's
clever how they've got the guy's face
away from us so they don't really have
to show his scroll mask on later at the
border they do do it but hey you've got
you've got to save some money on the
budget where you can anyway we catch
Fury making a good by colder hair which
is something we've seen other characters
doing in the MCU Tony Stark did it a
pepper before he flew up into the portal
in Avengers and I was thinking you know
put put some emotion into a fury now
shock horror big twist this is actually
Gaia and re-watching this scene knowing
this it makes a lot more sense I don't
say I love you or talk about anything on
an emotional level and Vera seems
surprised that they managed to get out
there so quickly so in hindsight you
know the coldness you feel here makes a
lot of sense as it's Sky ringing Vara
and not Fury ringing his wife now I will
be referring to them as fury because
it's gonna get confusing otherwise but
yeah just bear in mind that this is
actually Gaia she's still carries the
iodide pills though and as we know in
real life these protect from radiation
however this is all part of an act as we
learn in episode one that scrolls are
actually immune to the radiation
reactors give off guy shows that she
knows his scroll tactics inside out and
even uses a decoy card to draw the gods
away they end up using up most of their
bullet it's on this leaves them
distracted which allows guy to then kill
him a good Fury so I have gone back on
my own rules either way I really like
the way it started and she doesn't
forget to double tap John Wick's style
to make sure they're definitely dead
seeing her heading in we then go to
London and catch a roadie scroll trying
to convince president ritzen to fire
back at Russia however those around him
they're trying to de-escalate the
situation and there's also mention of
President vladimov this is the first
time I think we've actually had a name
for the Russian leader in the MCU and it
does sort of build out the rest of the
world and characters now ready scroll
has to change the story about the attack
to make sure that scrolls are included
in it Carlos being there meant the story
had to change unless they just couldn't
pin it all on the Russians to make
matters worse Russian tanks are also
taking a position on the Finland and
Ukrainian border we actually had rumors
last year that elements of this series
would include Ukraine without being a
big plot that Russia went against them
however this ended up being cut due to
being too similar to real life and I was
surprised that they still left this line
in however she ends up getting
manipulated herself as Sony that informs
her Furies heading to the hospital in
hindsight I love how there's these two
Furies in play and yeah it is nice to
have two super Scrolls facing off
against each other whilst Fury takes
them all you know the easier one with
the normal Roadie out at the reactor
side Fury or rather Gaia makes her way
in and they pass by Beto's body which
was left there by graphic last week lots
of other Scrolls have been killed too
and yeah from guy's perspective you can
see how you know this makes a bit of a
difference
she was a person who of course brought
him into the reactor and seeing him dead
yeah you know it it does kind of hit
home for her at this point Fury I'm just
gonna keep calling him fury because
otherwise he'll get confusing but at
this point Fury enters the reactor
coughing like you when you smoke one of
your uncle's wacky cigarettes graphic
reveals that everyone's locked away and
this of course leaves just these two
where is everybody
locked away looks like it's just you and
me fury I actually appreciate that
graphic cause I'm fury because we've
seen with other Scrolls how they messed
up and called them Nick this is what
gave Rody away to him and it shows how
gravic knows him on a personal level
friends call me fury is how the saying
goes and it shows that they've actually
had a friendship in the past Gaia plays
her role perfectly and she ends up
dropping the pills raising the tension
and making us think all's lost just
jumping back a bit I also like how she
asks about whether the scrolls are as
she would of course care about what's
happened to her friends offered a drink
graphic gives a toast to The Last Stand
of the great Nick Fury
but you clearly haven't read the script
or even seen the Marvel's trailer which
they dropped in advance giving it away
that Fury was gonna be fine I'm Nick
Fury
even when I'm out
I'm in now back at the hospital Rory
Scrolls starts moving out the president
as they're paranoid that Fury could
reveal the truth I like how they kind of
hide who's taking the gods out and this
makes us focus on Fury being with kravik
gravic talks about whose face he took
which guy of course doesn't know about
this makes gravic think it's because
Fury doesn't remember when in fact it's
actually because she has no idea who it
is this reflects how Scrolls and the
comics could easily get caught out
because they didn't take on the memories
of those that they were playing now I
think that the series has shown that the
Scrolls can work really well as villains
in the MCU other Bridges have been
mended I think they should still have
the bad Scrolls popping up in the
universe we know that Emperor dragay is
out there reeling over the rest of them
and potentially they might end up
launching attacks on Earth in the comics
it was Emperor Dora who ordered the
collection of the hero's DNA and this
somewhat mirrors what happened with the
Harvest before the events of secret
Invasion he actually captured the
Illuminati and worked out ways to then
clone the heroes this got to the point
that they perfectly brought across their
memories and the read wretched clones
even woke up believing they were him
eventually it did get to the point where
they realized and went mad because of
this but I hope at least something like
this is brought forth with the future of
the species we know that the Scrolls
that on Earth are with the emperor and
they might see the ones on Earth being
persecuted as being a slight on their
people this could lead to a proper
secret Invasion Story down the line
though that's probably me just about
getting wishful thinking either way I
think the real Fury would know who
graphic first killed but Guy having no
idea doesn't tip him off turns out
graphic feels Guild over killing the man
in a furious orders and it shows how
he's turned his agents into murderers
and assassins gravic was pretty much
okay when it came to Earth and it shows
how few didn't care about drafting kids
into his War Kingsley benedier
completely kills it in this moment and
the man goes off oozing true anger and
rage at this point Fury or ogaya or
whatever says they knew then a few years
that there was no home for the Scrolls
whether this is true or not I don't
really know though it does come across
as being sincere however Gaia is of
course delivering this so this speech
might not be real and we'll talk later
on about how the Marvel's trailer shows
Scrolls alongside Carol nagaya's Theory
says that when she was snapped she felt
relief but we know the real Nick Fury
was desperately reaching out to Captain
Marvel he's even saying mother so yeah I
do kind of take this as being her just
making it up now at this point she pulls
out the Harvest giving [__] to it and
playing up the fact that contains Carl
danver's DNA the Harvest itself is
actually being described online as the
most dangerous weapon on Earth and
though you know they do touch upon it I
don't feel like the show fully hammers
home that idea however it does build off
some of the Thematic elements that we
have seen popping up in phases four and
five the earlier faces came with the
idea that the next World War would be
fought with superhumans and though
that's an Amanda well a quote it's also
the case here too ever since the
creation of Captain America the has been
trying to reproduce her skins
experiments to go make super soldiers
this ended up leading to the creation of
the Hulk when the experiments went awry
and it's gonna be a big focus in Captain
America Brave New World now these plot
threads were further built upon in civil
war with us learning that the Russians
had been running their own Super Soldier
program if you've seen Oppenheimer then
you'll probably have noticed the
similarities between this and the arms
race and it shows a threat of escalation
with everyone trying to get their own
super soldiers in both Falcon and the
Winter Soldier we had a US agent being
created and also the flag smashes having
their super soldier serum too She-Hulk
had the intelligenture attempting to
make their own Hulks and there's this
idea here that you need to up your army
to be able to match the superhumans the
Scrolls didn't originally have
superpowers in the comics but after
being beaten by The Fantastic Four they
decided to up their game this led to
them creating experiments to make a
super scroll and if gravity gets these
Powers he'll be almost Unstoppable again
it's his idea of escalation and how if
America or humans do one thing thing
then everyone else has to at least match
them or better them they start carrying
knives their villains start carrying
guns they hit the thumbs up button their
villains subscribe once the Avengers
defeat the chitari Thanos had to get his
outriders and eventually ended up having
to step in himself what Graphics doing
makes a lot of sense and that's why the
Harvest has become so important it also
retroactively explains how gravic got
the extremis group DNA Frost beasts and
so on they were probably collected by
the Scrolls from the sites that these
things were located at but the Harvest
itself is a more refined version with
all the heroes who showed up during the
Battle of Earth thus it's got everyone
he'd want razzy's earlier versions they
don't have that roster now Gaia begs
gravic to take the Harvest and leave
which I actually think is her trying to
save her people it's kind of a last
chance deal before she reveals the truth
but then gravic takes it thinking he's
leaving PewDie die going over to the
machine with it we see lots of names
popping up and I did slow down the
footage to see everyone in it this thing
include a ghost Captain America corvus
glaive Thanos and outrider Proxima
midnight Captain Marvel the Abomination
mantis collabsidian Drax Korg ebony
Moore a frost Beast the chittori Black
Panther Valkyrie Thor Gamora Flora
Colossus and the Winter Soldier and the
play here is of course to allow guy to
power herself up as well and we do see
later on her demonstrating these
abilities at the hospital Sonia pulls a
gun sorting out how bad Rowdy is
tactically because the scroll doesn't
check behind the doors with gravic we
watch as the machine Powers up and it
gives the pair the abilities of the
Harvest a huge add to the Canadian Vapor
guy for pointing out that the machine in
the core Works in acts like the mutate
machine from the original X-Men movie
even the waves that come out look like
how they did in the film and they alter
DNA in the same way to help create
mutants mutants are slowly coming into
the MCU and if you've seen our videos on
Deadpool 3 then you'll know it's gonna
be in a big way now if you want to
support the channel and get that's a
merch out of it then check out our
secret Invasion spied scroll fiction
t-shirt riffing off the Quentin
Tarantino classic we've sourced out the
highest quality t-shirts we could find
and these are designed to accentuate and
show off your body in a flattering way
they're built up around the upper chest
and hang loose around the stomach so
they make you look better than you
already do link is in the description or
head over to shopzeroedition.com to get
your hands on one now thanks
at this point we see graphic looking
hulk-like and this may actually hint at
something coming down the line in the
comics hulkling is actually part scroll
himself so this might be a stepping
stone to how he gets introduced now
stabbing his face we watch his Guy
starts to fight back and this lead to
destroying the factory around them nice
catches that when grab it crash lands he
actually has groot's arm along with his
hulkish body at the hospital Fury steps
forward and we see Gaia then cycling
through the powers gravity gets what I
think is the abomination's arm whilst on
the other side of this we see guy gets
Traxxas looks a bit like that bit from
Rick and Morty where he's got the one
big on from doing you know what and we
see as they go through all the different
powers like Korg and the frost beasts
kind of devolves into a big CGI fight
which unfortunately I feel has plagued a
lot of the Marvel finale's the best one
for me has been the ending of Loki which
went with a more cerebral battle using
brains rather than Brawn meanwhile
written does the older I don't know who
to trust I don't know who to shoot which
is when Fury reveal also where leaders
are being kept hidden at the factory the
reason the Scrolls wanted to blow it up
was because all these VIPs were here and
bring this down would lead to Humanity's
downfall now from here we courtesy is
silo launching up and getting things in
place to begin firing missiles now this
Silo design look I know I know that
silos look like this in real life but
the design of this specific one looks
identical to how it was in Civil War I
think thematically lacing the entry with
iconography like this is to Plate the
themes that the entire show is sort of
its own little Civil War Fury and the
skrulls were originally on the same side
but after ideologies changed they ended
up turning against each other now we do
know from the Marvel's trailer that
everything will be fun and Danny with
them again so on the whole they'll
probably be welcome back we know there's
Scrolls on saber too so this is really
just a fraction of them that turned
against Fury now this could also be
showing how Humanity's turn on itself
but Fury starts to talk written around
to his side all he wants is for him to
delay the strike and get his head around
stop before going to war with Gaia we
see she uses the powers of Captain
Marvel before harnessing mantis to send
gravic to sleep crashing into the ground
she eventually blasts a hole through him
that reminded me a bit of when Carol
tried to take the Power Stone graphic is
killed along with the scroll Roadie and
for the moment the big scroll threat is
over now Ritz and gets on the horn and
Gaia Frieza trapped humans including the
Daltons and the guy we saw in episode 1
there's also Roadie alongside Everett
Ross though we don't get it cleared up
exactly when they were captured they say
it's a long time but we don't get dates
however we can see that he has trouble
walking in me you know I'm 56 years old
damn
I'm sorry
he was of course paralyzed during Civil
War and also had the braces in Avengers
Infinity War these appeared in the
opening of endgame and also at the
funeral however during Falcon in the
Winter Soldier he didn't have them on
I'm guessing that the brace thing is the
biggest clue to this all and that it's
probably just going to be that project
though yeah we will find out in the
future the PM is freed along with the
guy Pagan imitated and we see his Ritz
and puts out a call that declares
Scrolls his enemy combatants I will talk
about this more in depth later on and
how it's going to lead into something in
the future either way from here we could
have crossed a Fury's home and see him
back rocking his classic look he fled to
saber after the events of endgame but
he's now returned to Earth to right the
wrongs of the past it's been said he's
at his stair man behind his opponents
but now he's back in black and ready to
protect the planet last week he said it
was a personal problem which is why he
wouldn't reach out to the Avengers and
he has to be the man to protect Earth
this is something that happened in the
comics too an original sin centered
around and finally died dying and giving
up the mantle was a great story but it
also hammered home the idea that Fury
has to be the man looking out for us now
he apologizes for not being there and
Vara talks about how she has to put a
mask on whenever he's around he finally
says that he loves her and he's back to
ask for one more chance at love with
Gaia we see she gets Tracked Down by
Sonia and then off but a deal Gaia
actually might be the most powerful
person on the planet at this point and
Sonia someone wants to draft her into a
cold war however Sonia wants to offer
the Scrolls a place on Earth rather than
the deal that Talos had with Theory
makes sense that things would go in this
direction and at this point we see Fury
reaches out to the president whilst this
is going on we get it into space with
how many Scrolls there are and how many
humans that they discovered this room
full of people somewhat riffs off the
comics as the Scrolls kept a group of
world leaders today dead Wilds they took
over their roles a lot of people are
asking why the Scrolls don't out and out
kill people and personally I think it's
connected to the memories they might
worry one day that they'll need certain
information and this won't be accessible
if the target's dead for example it
could be the new codes or even personal
info that they need to know to not
arouse suspicion in episode 3 we saw how
Telos call Guy to get her to read Bob
fairbank's mind and this may be
something that kravik's forces also have
to do too and the bodies here are
covered in a sort of plasticky fabric
seal or something that looks like skin
and to me this has been done for a
specific reason Invasion of the Body
Snatchers had people being put into pods
and the aliens then duplicated and
copied them exactly discovering these
identities has led to hit squads going
out and assassinating all the members of
the scroll Council this has obviously
led to things escalating further and it
has inspired lots of different
vigilantes in a sense have obviously
been caught in the crossfire with people
who aren't Scrolls being shot themselves
Britain has declared war though and
refuses to back down and I'm gonna reach
here for a second but look at the driver
don't know if it's a light or what but
either way it's shot to give this guy a
green and purple looking face as we know
these are the colors of the Scrolls
perhaps hitting that they're closer than
he thinks Fury also taunts him as being
a one-time president which are obvious
political commentary reflecting our
world there anyway Fury goes back to the
ship but Barrow returns in a sort of
reverse E.T moment the alien is watching
the human leave the planet but she
finally shows her true face giving us a
tender moment she's decided to use her
true name and we learn that the cree are
also open to peace talks Barre is unsure
on whether it's gonna go well but Fury
wants her to join him at the peace
Summit now according to the leaks on the
Marvels this will actually feature in
the film but yeah whether that's the
case or we'll just have to wait and see
Barra shows her true face and the pair
say that they love each other which I'm
not crying mate you're crying no
promises she'll never have to hide her
face again but mate you could he could
be with Cameron Diaz in The Mask you
know what I'm saying
good parts of it yeah now as for where
the MCU is going to go from here we
actually have a pretty fair idea due to
Marvel's spoiling all the upcoming films
no idea why they released the Marvel's
trailer last week but I'm guessing that
from now on Fury is going to operate
primarily out of cyber this is a
satellite that protects here from
extraterrestrial threats and it makes
sense that it's located right next to a
hex point you can catch this up in the
top left and it's gonna have Fury
keeping his eyes sorry I on what's
happening out in space now we also know
that arm Awards is on the way too with
Rory being the main character in that I
think that's going to fill in a lot of
questions people have like exactly when
he was swapped out Kevin varghes
actually said that Roddy was a scrolling
of the project so hopefully we'll get
the ins and outs of exactly when that
was now all my Wars will probably build
off the back of the power broker reveal
in Falcon in the Winter Soldier guessing
lots of Iron Man suits will be contested
for and that will be the main thrust of
that film elsewhere we have the events
of this show also leading into Captain
America Brave New World by the time that
film rolls around General Ross will be
the president with the events of this
show clearly affecting ritson's run this
similar mirrors the comics as in those
Tony Stark to cover as a leader of
SHIELD in the wake of Civil War however
his leadership was seen as a liability
after the Scrolls infiltrated all
aspects of his life he posed as Jarvis
released a virus had sabotaged his Tech
and brought down every aspect of Shield
it was actually Norman Osborne that
ended up taking down the Scrolls and
because of this he was appointed as the
new leader he brought in the dark
Avengers at this point which is a
similar Arc to what I can see Ross going
through think once he gets to the point
of being the president he'll start the
Thunderbolts program which will then
lead us directly into the Thunderbolts
movie now lastly we have the Marvels
which is gonna be the next MCU film
released from the trailer we have an
idea of what happened when Carol went
out looking for a new home for the
Scrolls and we now know that she
returned back to Hala yeah she destroyed
the Supreme intelligence and the people
from the planet now call her the
annihilator we have done a full video
breaking down the entire trailer for
that so I don't want to just repeat it
but Scrolls will be making an appearance
in the movie alongside Carol so they'll
probably touch upon what the plan is
next and we might build off the back of
this season to finally get the Scrolls a
new home as are my thoughts on the
season as a whole I think that's
unfortunately missed its full potential
and though it was solid it didn't end up
hitting the Great Heights that I feel it
could have I feel this is a problem
that's plagued Disney Plus shows across
the board and it's something Bob Iger
has even admit himself I don't know if
it's the six episode format that holds
things back but it feels like by the
time we finally get things going it's
time to wind it down we now know that
Daredevil born again will be split into
two parts with us getting two nine
episode arcs and a break in between I
think that's probably a better format
because I just don't think these short
limited series are allowing the creative
teams to excel when I think of secret
Invasion I think of a big threat where
all the heroes are constantly
questioning what's going on and who they
can really trust the series start off
with those themes but once the
characters started dropping off it
became pretty obvious how things were
gonna go been thinking about this in the
week and I think the movie The Thing
should have been the archetype for what
they ended up doing in this show like
the series that has a small cast and
also a villain that can perfectly mimic
people however that's lace with a
constant feeling of paranoia because you
don't really know who could be the thing
this series kinda started out like that
too and the Everett Ross reveal was
something that completely caught me off
guard a thing that after the death of
Maria though that all the potential
scroll candidates became pretty obvious
Brody was the only Avenger that could be
and them having the reveal over the
phone instead of through a character
robbed us of their reactions when you
read the comics you have this constant
feel of surprise and you don't really
know who to trust but that just didn't
feel like it was apparent here though we
were talking about it being an event
that could set up World War III you also
didn't really get that feeling and it
just boiled down to a bad guy trying to
gain more power and this is a shame
because when the show saw was it really
really sorts as some brilliant acting in
this series and I think all of the
strongest moments happened when it was
just two characters going back and forth
Samuel L Jackson knocked it out of the
park and we had some brilliant moments
with them going against Ben mendelsohn
Kobe smolders and Charlene Woodard this
was my favorite performance from him as
Nick and I thought Olivia Coleman really
shined too she completely killed it and
gleefully ate up all the scenes that she
was in as well Emilia Clarke as always
handled things brilliantly and she
brought strength and vulnerability which
is what made her betrayal of Daenerys so
good in the first place I just don't
think she was given enough to work with
and that's the same with Kingsley
benedier the first few episodes of the
series had him being a twisted and
complex villain that on some levels you
could at least relate to he was
intimidating but his plan to take things
from himself was something he could see
actually proving to be a pretty
dangerous threat however by the latter
part of the seasons he just became a bit
stereotypical and he lost a lot of the
Nuance that he had early on so yeah
there's some good stuff yeah but a lot
feels like half-formed ideas that they
had to cram into this six episode thing
and I'll probably sound like I'm overly
bashing it as I did enjoy it but I just
expected more twists more paranoia and
something that felt like it was going to
destroy them all the universe rather
than being a nuisance now saying that I
think it's still probably one of the
stronger MCU shows and so far my ranking
goes Loki number one one division two
then probably Moon Knight and secret
Invasion tied alongside Ms Marvel in
third place those those could really
swap numbers depending on what day you
ask me and after that I'd have Falcon in
the Winter Soldier following Hawkeye is
kind of in the same league for me what
if after that and She-Hulk being my
least favorite out there now I don't
know what the formats of the shows is
going to be going forward because echo's
getting released in one day which has
spark conversations that it's because
the series is pretty met we also have
the Agatha series coming out and
ironheart as well along with Loki season
2 and of course Daredevil now there is
talk that these shows damaging the brand
and yeah I think when they're just okay
it does hurt people's interest in Marvel
it just seems like we're teasing endless
sequels and rather than going anywhere
it's about the next project and what's
to come down the line I am again I'm
being a bit of a Negative Nancy but I'm
just being realistic and giving both the
the positives of the show and what I
feel could have been stronger I come
across like I thought was terrible and I
want to make sure that I didn't think
that you know I did enjoy parts of it
but yeah this whole thing just just fell
short of hitting that absolutely amazing
level now I will turn that over to you
because it is just my opinion what did
you think on the series and do you think
these shows are killing the brand if at
all comment below and let me know and if
you want to support the channel as a
member of the spoiler Society then
please click the join Button as we
really appreciate it you get early
access to videos every single week and
it goes such a long way to helping us
all out now if you wanted me else to
watch we've got a breakdown of the
Marvel's trailer which will be linked on
screen right now be said over there if
you want to hear more of our thoughts on
what secret animation could go and how
it picks up in the movie and yeah is
what's happening with Carol by the way
huge thank you for clicking this I've
been Paul hope you've enjoyed the
coverage and yeah I'll see you next time
you take care yourself mate thank you
much love a peace